over the weekend word emerged via a
interview that uh i think the full
interview is coming up this weekend but
jeff darlington of espn sitting down
with tom brady and
tom brady being asked point blank is
there any chance you retire after super
bowl 53 and he put that storyline to bed
even before he got to town
zero chance of a retirement after super
bowl 53. zero money so we can put here
zero point zero mystery
0.0 it could be 0.9 0.1 i still think
that there's a chance he does not want
to even let it enter his mind until
after the super bowl is over and then
and then after the super bowl is over
it's a different existence altogether
especially when his wife says tommy
we we talked about this two years ago
when you beat the falcons and we're
gonna talk about it now you have six
you've had concussions remember she
blurted that out i don't think that was
an accident a year and a half ago and i
think that she's gonna be a big factor
in the final decision and i and i i
don't blame him for saying zero chance
for now the reason why i think he's
absolutely not going to retire is very
simple
i think the super bowl is really fun for
him uh and he loves being here it's the
culmination of everything blah blah blah
but the other thing is mike it's the
other nine months a year when he really
starts getting into football he likes
that just as much he likes going to work
with tom house and having his mechanics
sort of put under a microscope he likes
getting better at that he likes throwing
with his friends he likes doing the
football stuff he's one of the only guys
he loves training camp i mean he loves
football so it's easy to say well you
win another one you might walk away
you're 41 and a half years old but it's
it would be different if he said oh my
god i got to go through this again he
does he's not like that he loves every
part of this job that's why he's not
walking away i don't think there's any
chance either and he can still do it
that's the thing and and the challenge
is
to do it
and hold off father time and there was a
stretch this year when his knee was
banged up that it looked like maybe
father tom is finally catching up to him
and you don't want it to happen during a
season you don't want to have that one
last embarrassing year where it's all
falling apart and there was a limited
window where it felt like it was moving
in that direction which fed this idea
that nobody believes in the patriots
anymore because they had those two games
where they gave us reason to not believe
you know he is he has he has played in
three straight super bowls at 39 and a
half 40 and a half and 41 and a half i
think that you know you talk about nine
super bowls in in 18 years that's
amazing i believe it is just as amazing
for a guy who basically is 39.5 40 and a
half 41 and a half in three straight
years playing in the super bowl not only
playing
but coming back from 28 to 3 to beat the
falcons putting up 505 yards last year
you know in the loss to philadelphia and
then whatever happens this year but he's
playing out of control right now anyway
so i mean he's going to play i think
he's going to play a good game in this
one yeah it's a we've never seen this i
i i say more than not just in football i
don't think we've seen this in pro
sports
why don't you on saturday and i'm i'm
saying this half jokingly yeah stand up
in the room at the hall of fame meeting
and say
let's just go ahead and put this guy in
now oh we already know that we already
know that he's in so it doesn't matter
but he lives it and he shouldn't retire
because he's still playing good i think
he's trying to one-up jordan i think
he's trying to go out with seven and do
like be the greatest american sports
icon and the game is easy for him you
know i don't think people are gonna take
this like i'm not trying to take a swipe
at him here either it's easy for him
because he's seen everything and they
make it easy for him you know he
struggled during that part of the year
because they weren't running the ball as
good and they couldn't protect but now
they're protecting running the ball and
he dices them up do you know what your
father said to me right after he retired
he was like i think he was 38 yes right
after he retired he goes you know the
saddest part of retiring right now is i
have just figured everything out nobody
can throw something yeah i don't know
right and i think that's the way he
breaks
right now by the easiness yeah gets
everything exactly and as long as he can
do it he'll keep doing it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports